le haut carabar de nouveau sous les
bombes azéri ce mardi 19 septembre
l'Azerbaïdjan a lancé une opération
militaire d'envergure contre la
république autoproclamée du haut-karaba
depuis ce matin la capitale Stéphane
hacker et d'autres villes de la région
sont ciblées par des tirs intensifs
selon les autorités locales tandis que
l'armée azéri tente d'avancer en
profondeur les forces arméniennes du
haut-karaba ont déclaré résisté sur
toute la ligne de contact deux civils
tués et 23 blessés seraient déjà à
déplorer des opérations antiterroristes
ont commencé dans la région dans le
cadre de ces mesures les positions des
forces armées arméniennes sont mises
hors d'état de nuire à l'aide d'armes de
haute précision sur la ligne de front et
en profondeur opération antiterroriste
pour Bakou agression en cherchant à
parachever sa politique de nettoyage
ethnique selon Erevan cette opération
militaire marque un nouvel épisode dans
la guerre pour le contrôle de cet
enclave peuplé d'Arménien mais rattaché
juridiquement à laserbaïdjan cette
annonce intervient 3 ans après
l'opération point d'acier lancé par
Bakou en septembre 2020 et qui avait
débouché sur un encore de cesser le feu
signé sous l'égide de Moscou l'objectif
affiché de Bakou est aujourd'hui
d'obtenir le retrait inconditionnel et
total des forces armées arméniennes de
la région azerbaïdjanaise du karabach et
la dissolution de la République
arménienne autoproclamée mais la
réintégration forcée de la région dans
l'Azerbaïdjan expose les populations
arméniennes locales à un risque de
nettoyage ethnique alerte Erevan pour
justifier le lancement de cette nouvelle
phase d'hostilité Bakou a invoqué la
mort de quatre policiers et deux civils
dans des explosions de mines dans la
région imputée à des séparatifs
Arméniens tandis que l'Arménie appelle
les forces de maintien de la paix russe
déployées dans la région à stopper
l'agression Moscou affirme avoir été
mise au courant par Bakou seulement
quelques minutes avant le lancement de
l'opération
française Catherine Colonna a dénoncé
une opération illégale injustifiable et
inacceptable pour cette nouvelle phase
de stilité Bakou jouit cependant d'un
avantage militaire significatif fort du
soutien de la Turquie et de Saman
pétrolière les forces azeries
préparaient cette offensive de longue
date depuis plusieurs semaines
l'Azerbaïdjan acheminé du matériel
militaire et des troupes longs de la
frontière avec l’arts de nombreux vols
en provenance d'Israël qui fournit de
l'équipement militaire de haute
technologie à bas coût avait été destiné
le choix du calendrier nait lui non plus
pas un hasard analyse Jean-Christophe
buisson directeur adjoint du Figaro
Magazine en 2020 laserbaïdjan avait
profité des élections américaines pour
attaquer la tsar aujourd'hui il profite
de l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies pour lancer sa nouvelle offensive
[Musique]